today guys this is gonna obsess you
today is Harry Potter's 37th birthday
whoa no so so break because it just
makes everyone feel old but hey go ahead
and break out the butter beer or if
you're a designated driver a teetotaler
like me and break happy I can't believe
it's not butter beer and because the end
of the Deathly Hallows is set in
September 2017 this is how Harry
actually looks right now this is how
they look they sort of like that sadly
30s guy you see wandering the frozen
food section of Trader Joe's that's what
it looks like just think about what his
life is like right now 37 year old
dropout who peaked in high school
married his childhood sweethearts trying
to raise a family on the combined pay of
a government employee and a newspaper
reporter ball the board couldn't kick
his ass but time definitely did - trying
to relive yeah go on Harry Potter
pushing middle-age what is it fella 37
year old wizard would you yes sir an
invisibility cloak to help him avoid
paying child support all right boys ah
where are we yet great saloon viagra
Cadabra yes
ah
I mean that's kind of cute the Feli
would probably use its Petrificus
Totalus
but that's fine rifle thing hold my wand
I had too much petronas all right boy